Hosting a good party is all about
good preparation
good snacks
good drinks
good tunes
But even with good planning, parties can still go pear-shaped.
So make sure you register your party at goodone.org.nz
The Good One website has heaps of tips
for making sure your event goes off without a hitch
and by registering, police, fire and noise
control know who to get in touch with if
there's a problem on the night.
Simply enter the details of your party
The local police will call for a quick chat about your plans
and then have a great time.
and if things do start to get a bit
hairy
the police can pop by and help out
So, whether you're a student, parent
sports club or other - be a great host.
Register your party and make sure you have a good one.
North Canterbury,  it's now
your turn to have a good one with a
voucher book jam-packed full of free stuff
and discounts for the first 50 parties
registered in the Waimakariri